when Minnesota picked up jail in the
well and Nasri and now a technical is
gonna be calm in both hands is gonna mix
it up
Shrieve getting in there
[Applause]
Fujio
man chill out
James torching he's been a topless here
they brought him here to teach us that
did not take any crap I love the fact
that Jeff Albert to it but his face
let's see what he's upset about what the
technical foul is on call her friend
to the hospital after the turn
didn't do that you don't do that that
let's you've done it before I said what
is you sayin I don't there may have been
an extra word in there yeah I'd like to
competitiveness of Derrick Coleman but
you gotta earn that a little bit better
be able to do that little bit more
before you get dark Smith why don't you
play against the best team of the league
yeah and you gotta be aware of the
situation you're hanging with the best
team in the league and their heroes make
them mad you don't want to push you
don't want to give him an extra point I
love to play them deep in the core he
loves it everybody loves it everybody